[Music]
from DC the studio who hides the hero's
faces in their intro because they're all
about to get recast comes a follow-up to
their breakout hit Shazam where shazam's
greatest Nemesis finally faces off
against whoever these guys are in a film
whose biggest selling point is the after
credit scene whoa the rock is gonna
fight Superman and he's gone
Black Adam
slow down the old Noggin for a superhero
flick that asks nothing of his audience
but to open up and say where the themes
never get deeper than talk versus punch
fighting won't solve this I disagree me
too characters blurred out the backs of
their own trading cards the Nanobots
were injected into my bloodstream by
this really messed up scientist who
kidnapped me when I was 15. and you can
feel the screenwriter writing put
something better here later than never
going back for a second draft our
mission is to protect global stability
we're here to restore peace to conduct
and we will use Force if necessary oh
yeah that's the good stuff exposing me
baby inter Gang has taken over kandak
for its precious eternium now Black Adam
will come out of his cave to stop them
but this resurrected Middle Eastern
savior is less Jesus and more Zoo zoos
foreign
Rises to the top of the DC universe's
hierarchy of power totally a thing and
just keeps on Rising
and Rising
until he's a video game character with
infinite health and 5 stars on GTA
[Applause]
no point in fighting we both know no one
can stop me yeah we know can we just end
the movie then
return to ancient times when the legend
of teth Adam began and meet a young boy
destined to become the people's champion
and perhaps someday deliver the people's
elbow uniting them all under the symbol
of Rockefeller records in a series of
fake out flashbacks that are supposed to
make you think this kid is Young Black
Adam but the twist gets spoiled when
they keep showing the rock right next to
him there that's you Dwayne we can still
touch you when you're facing away no one
else looks that much like a really buff
hot dog fighting him is the Justice
Society repeatedly until everyone gets
bored with the idea how long we gonna
keep doing this they're a correct team
of whoever Amanda Waller can get in the
phone there's Hawkman a billionaire
crime fighter that Bruce Wayne just kind
of forgot about when he was putting the
Justice League together Dr Fate a Mystic
who gets all hot and bothered whenever
he rubs the tip of his helmet
oh
Adam Smasher a bumbling elf you bring
along when you really need the locals to
hate you I am so sorry was that
expensive but like his Uncle says hey
forget about it and Maxine a manic pixie
dream tornado with all the powers and
charm of a human Vape meanwhile among
the mere mortals there's Adriana she can
read men who are given the gift of magic
god of gods sexy Mortal Elders by name
this
is the only path to life this big guy he
can sing
[Applause]
and Amman he's so cool to the max he has
seven different skateboards me this
do-over of Freddie Freeman from Shazam
with less Charisma have you seen up your
outfit a little bit get a cape change
your name his name is uh Captain sparkle
fingers no it's not no it's not a kid
who knows all the DC heroes except
Shazam nobody ever mentioned Shazam
Superman Batman Aquaman you're way more
stacked than any of them and in the year
of our lore 2022 he's still doing the
let's work on your catchphrase joke tell
them the men in blackcentre yes but not
to me say to the bad guys but before you
zap them nailed it and just in time for
the 30-year anniversary of Terminator 2
but still good job and if you want to
shine them on it's hasta la vista baby
hasta la vista baby
so even though the hierarchy of the DC
Universe has actually changed sending
the rock into full-blown damage control
mode our margins don't live and die by
box office numbers it has long uh
um very long uh tentacles and most of
the dceu died on the way back to their
home planets make room for a meat and
potato story that gets the job done a
Pierce Brosnan who's only getting more
easy on the eyes and most importantly
it's got just enough PG-13 brutality to
give grown men an alibi for watching a
400 million dollar cartoon see there
honey here's that other man's arm off
only big boys are allowed to see that
now let's go get you a video game on the
way home what do you say
Story the way the Kool-Aid Man Johnson
oh yeah cash money's Birdman Gold Bond
Medicated powers can man Halle Bailey
Laura soft the anti-anti-hero so wait
the hero a rude myself today to see if I
still feel and the Snyder cuts
foreign
[Music]
ruins everything
all right the main villain I remember
literally nothing about him and neither
will you
he did a sky beam it's cute
to you yeah bunny
I am mighty Ray fear my eyeballs the
line from Taken JB Davey Crockett King
of the Wild Frontier auto parts in
trouble exploding planet